could you tell me what brought you out
here today um well i'm in denver to
protest the Democratic National
Convention well the democrat party
platform has a provision that says we
should punish employers who hire
undocumented workers what your thoughts
on that more marching absolutely not
well I like as I said I'm for you know a
world without borders I mean I think
we're all I think you know I welcome
immigrants in this country I think it's
great with the kind i think there needs
to be more you know i'm an
internationalist not a nationalist you
know what why do you think this system
attracts immigrants well I mean let's
look let's look at this honestly you
have the fact that the world capitalist
system is actually crushed the economy
in Mexico where people used to be able
to live with self-sustaining farms in
agriculture now it's been all switch
over to copy to sell them international
markets so when the price of coffee
crashes the whole economy crushes along
with that so people have to come here or
look just for ways to work just to
survive now in the past in communist
countries generally people have tried to
move out of the country and not move in
I think that it's very difficult to be
good on immigrant issues without also
being good on on trade issues we if we
think of immigrants as sometimes as
economic refugees then we have to start
also in analyzing how are our trade
agreements undermining economies
elsewhere now I saw in the Democrat
platform there's a provision that we
should crack down on employers who hire
undocumented workers what are your
thoughts on that absolutely that was
that's what was supposed to happen in
1986 when the law was passed back then
but no one enforced the law and
President Bush decided to enforce it
basically the last 12 months but he had
seven years to enforce the law and he
didn't do it he also had seven years
almost eight years to pass comprehensive
immigration reform and he didn't do it
either so there's been a massive failure
on the part of President Bush and that's
why we now have states and cities and
local communities passing laws that are
very unjust and in many cases very
punitive against undocumented workers
and that's what we need reform at the
federal level now I saw in the democrat
party platform they say we should crack
down on employers who hire undocumented
workers what are your thoughts on that
generally I believe that if you want to
deal with this if you think this is just
a PI problem the way that you deal to
supply problems always a demand however
I think sometimes when we talk about
employer sanctions and we go to the
extreme when we end up hurting the
workers we're looking to protect so it
has to be a much more balanced approach
and the devil's always in the details
and those haven't been hammering out
that so um you are not supportive of
like the rage that are going on at
different businesses around the country
generally not because they only serve
one purpose which is to terrorize in my
opinion and it also splits up families